county school district mariachi band
gets a major gig
students will be actually performing at
the presidential inauguration tomorrow
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us how they're representing nevada
not only with music but culture
[Music]
las vegas high school are set to perform
on the national stage
never once did i think that we would be
able to have this opportunity to perform
for the president of the united states
angel miramontes and his classmates will
represent nevada in the virtual parade
across america
during the presidential inauguration an
unexpected honor for the senior
who plays violin in the group we're
going to be performing our
own tema our own team and
mariachi
[Music]
a video online teases the upcoming
appearance a pre-recorded virtual
production
they record themselves playing we put
all of the
music together we send them the final
music and then they record their video
[Music]
stephen blanco directs mariachi hoya he
says biden's team asked the group last
week to participate
it's not the first time though
performing for him the students played
for the president-elect when he visited
las vegas
last year i don't know of too many
things meaning more
principal ron gurzon says he is proud
but
he and blanco highlight the biggest
significance of this
celebrating different cultures
irrespective
of your background and your experience
you can
be successful my family is from mexico
so
it's a huge thing for me part of
showcasing in america united
kristin drummond 8 news now the event
will be
live stream starting at 12 15 tomorrow a
link will be on eightnewsnow.com what a
thrill for those talented local kids
we wish them the best we know they're
gonna knock it out of the park in that
big national performance
your forecast